For this project, I’m going to show you
how to eliminate the fear and panic of losing
your car keys, and the frustration of getting
locked out by your kids. Especially when your
keys, are locked inside with them.
Let’s start this project with a 45 lb. karabiner
hook magnet, and a bottle of kids vitamin
gummies. Save the gummies for your kids because
all we’re really after here is the plastic
container, and the reason I chose this bottle,
is because it’s fairly cheap, and the mouth
is wide enough for a key fob, to slide in
and out without any problems at all.
Now rather than making our own magnetic key
box, you might be wondering, “Why not just
go to the store and buy a pre-made case instead?”.
The answer is that you could, but they aren’t
big enough to store transponders and key fobs,
so they won’t work very well with newer vehicles.
The magnets aren’t impressively strong either.
I tested the store bought version on a flat
steel weight and found that the most it could
handle was 5 lbs … barely.
One the other hand, you can find super magnets
at the hardware store, that claim to hold up to 45lbs.
Now in practice, I found the most they’re
really good for is about 25 lbs. which is
nearly half of what’s advertised. But despite
the inflated claim, you can still see they’re
still at least 5 times stronger, and that
will make all the difference.
Now to make a car hero key box, we’ll need
our magnet secured firmly to the lid of the
bottle, and I found the easiest way to do
that is with a flat-head screwdriver and a
propane torch. Of course if you don’t have
a propane torch, you can always use a bbq igniter instead.
Get your screwdriver and carefully heat the
tip for a few seconds in the open flame so
it gets good and hot, then quickly press it
into the top of the lid so it makes a hole
that’s slightly offset from the center.
While it’s still hot, make another hole
in-line with the first, and you should end
up with a nice clean slit right down the center.
Now, when your screwdriver’s cooled down
a bit, gently pry at the edges of the bottle
cap liner, and pop it out so you can modify
the underside of the cap.
Heat the screwdriver again, but this time,
rather than poking all the way through the
cap, carefully carve a channel out of the
inner plastic lining, around half an inch
long on either side of the slit. Take your
time and do a good job, because it’s really
important that you don’t burn into the yellow
part of the cap underneath.
With this little channel carved out, go ahead
and unhook the karabiner from the magnetic
base, so you can flip it over and press karabiner
clip down into the cap, locking it into place
with the magnetic side facing up.
Now if you look closely at the underside of
the cap, it should start to make sense how
this is going to come together.
Try hooking the karabiner back in place, and
you’ll most likely find there’s just barely
enough clearance to get it lined up with the
hole. But with a little persistence, and some
leverage from your screwdriver, you should
be able to pull it all the way through. It’s
locked together pretty tight now, and that’s
really great, because it means there’s very
little chance it’s ever going to come off
by accident.
At this point, you’re pretty much done,
so go ahead and clip a spare set of keys onto
the karabiner, and that’s it.
You’ve got yourself a super strong, and
weather resistant, car hero key box. That’ll
accommodate an emergency set of keys, with
room to spare.
Now let’s go one step further and give it
a paint job.
I thought it would be fun to try coating it
with some abrasion resistant truck bed coating.
This stuff is normally used for lining truck
beds, but you can see it gives the bottle
a cool textured look, that will help camouflage
it a bit, so it blends in better with where
we’re going to hide it in a second.
Spray a couple of coatings on the cap as well,
because it’ll help seal the gaps around
the magnet, and make the whole thing water
resistant.
Now since your vehicle is built on a steel
frame, your super strong key box will stick
just about anywhere you want. And if you look
around for awhile you’ll see hundreds of
little nooks and crannies where you could
hide it, so pick a place that works best for
you, and your piece of mind.
Now the next time you walk out to your car
and realize your keys are missing, you don’t
have to worry about calling a friend for a
ride, or breaking a window to get in.
Instead, simply reach for your emergency key
box, and a clean set of spare keys,will be
waiting there, ready to help you out.
Just like that you’ve dodged a potentially
embarrassing situation, and emerged a car
hero instead. Saving you time, money, and maybe even your pride as well.
Well now you know how to convert a magnet
and plastic bottle into a car hero key box.
That’s over 5 times stronger than store
bought brands, and much more convenient to use.
By the way, try throwing a few hand wipes
in there as well. This way if you get a bit
dirty in the process, you’ll have something
handy, to wipe yourself clean.
That’s it for now. If you like this video,
perhaps you’ll like some of my others.
Check them out at www.thekingofrandom.com